living with yourself I was watching this
last night on Netflix and really loved
it I really love this show thank you and
it's a great idea and it also feels like
and I mean this in the in the best
possible sense it's very high quality
show it's also once you start watching
them it's kind of made to binge-watch
yeah one leads right into the next leads
right into the next they're not super
long and the next thing you know you're
just rocketing through the minutes
that's what you want more yeah that's
the way I felt when I was reading them
oh my gosh I'll read it because they
were all written and I thought well it's
kind of a good sign and it's also one of
the things that I like about the show
just because it's short there's only
eight of them and then there I don't
think they're half an hour because who
has time to even watch it anything it's
too daunting there's so much television
just I mean there's a little ton of
movies but when you even if you just say
television there's so much right let it
homework yeah I really you know it's
good yeah yeah I know I know how
incredible Game of Thrones is it's
amazing and I've never seen one episode
you've just been hearing about it I know
it's great but I also I'm not so sure
that that's where they've applause but
but I want to watch it but I probably
will never watch it it because it seems
a little bit like I missed the boat it's
too much work people are going are like
oh my god have you seen season two of
the crown I haven't seen season 1 of the
crown yeah and you have to sink a lot of
time into him and here's the other thing
you get a lot now which is there's a
show and there's three seasons and
there's you know 38 episode where do you
start when they'll say when you start at
the beginning
no but there's actually a good tip yeah
funny if I told people that didn't
really know my show I'd say you got to
start at the very beginning in 93 and
you got to watch all of them to really
get it but no people say this all the
time they say at first seasons kind of
slow first season or two but you got to
really sit through those cuz the third
season it really starts to pay off I'm
like no I have children and friends I
want to do things I want to see that you
sit tight for 20 hours yeah that's good
well it's a little it's a little bit
like somebody handing you a violin and
saying you should learn how to play that
you know how great that it can sound but
it takes it takes work this watching our
show isn't is it's the equivalent of
somebody say like oh you should learn
how to play golf or something do I miss
the boat I'm too old right me too our
show is like playing cornhole like
anybody even do it you don't have to is
that as the cornhole of TV
there's never been a better slogan ever
that's gonna be on a bus yeah but it's
fine you don't you don't know you don't
have to watch it we know it's a it's a
terrific show
I will bring people just up to speed
with the premise which I love the
premise you're a guy who's burnt out
tired of his life feeling like he needs
to be rejuvenated right you go to a very
mysterious place I don't want to give
away too much but I think I do need to
tell people that through and it all
makes sense when you watch the show you
replicate yourself yes yes on knowingly
yeah I am clone you are cloned and and
then very funny things and see we have a
clip here which clip is this I'm not
sure well there's there's there's if
you've seen the trailer the original
version of me in this show goes and it's
clothed but the I was supposed to die
and I don't and I kind of come up out of
a grave mm-hmm and I have to go
travelling kind of through the forest to
get back to my house it's in the first
episode but this this is a clip of me
kind of coming to and trying to get back
to figure out what's going on it's quite
a scene let's take a look at this clip
from living with yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so how many people in the audience were
like here we go why you gotta go
surprise you guys clearly many people
seen the trailer as you can see you need
there you see a little bit of the
cloning process yes yes that was the
nice surprise after all these years it
was nice to see he whistles something
different but we had a lot of fun on it
you could tell good you look you looked
good you look really good you really
don't age it's true what they say thank
you very much yeah I don't feel it
inside thank you do you want to show a
real clip you son of a [ __ ]
that was a real clip okay I did bring I
did bring a we can cut to the to the
real one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't have time to watch Game of
Thrones but you have time to do that
well it really wasn't a long shoot the
show trust me you should look at the
show it's fantastic it's called living
with yourself it's available now for
streaming on Netflix Paul Rudd there's
no other Paul Rudd there's certainly